if I were to ask you if you're happy
with your webcam quality I would bet
that most of you would say no even those
that have the newer MacBooks with the
finely upgraded 1080p webcams built in
like the 16-inch MacBook Pro I am in the
same boat especially if I'm not in a
bright room or a studio environment like
I am right now with a super large soft
light well that is where the Opel 4K
webcam comes in which not only has
amazing quality but is insanely easy to
set up and use has a ton of great
software features and is built like a
Tang I know that you're going to be very
impressed by it as were a ton of
YouTubers and creatives like MKBHD who
not only uses it even though he has
multi a hundred thousand dollars of
camera gear but he even personally
invested in the company for years I
looked for a webcam like this one and
while smartphones and digital camera
Tech was moving fast pretty much nothing
was happening in the web webcam space
which is why so many people's streams
and recordings still look so terrible
because of that there have been many
times where I've actually put away my
laptop and I pulled out my phone and set
it up on a box for a better angle when I
was FaceTiming with friends as well as
Zoom meetings for work well that is
where a small team of folks from Apple
Tesla and Google came together to start
Oppo not only did the camera design win
Awards but even the Box itself and you
could see why now what surprised me the
most is how extremely solid the camera
is being made out of metal and having
this industrial design the same thing
goes with the mounts and even the metal
tool they give you to attach it using
the quarter inch threads at the bottom
this thing can mount to almost anything
from a super thin MacBook display to my
thick 6K Pro display xdr and of course
you could put this on a tripod or any
other amount if you would like you also
get a super high quality USB type-c
cable which has a perfect fit and a
metal magnetic privacy cover with soft
fabric on one side to protect the lens
so overall the build quality is
outrageously good but what about the
image quality well I had really high
expectations but the results were even
better than I expected now the 1080p
footage from my 16 inch MacBook looks
its best in our studio lighting right
here but switching to the Opel in 1080P
mode makes a shocking difference with so
much more detail and even some natural
blur due to its large sensor switching
to 1440p the Quality gets even better
and then switching to 4K wow the image
quality is crazy looking like my very
expensive Sony mirrorless camera so I
knew that I had to compare it side by
side this setup has a 3005 500 camera in
a two thousand three hundred dollar lens
along with a bunch of extras that are
required to make it work and here is the
difference in image quality the Opel
actually has more sharpness which of
course you can turn down in the settings
if you would like but the overall image
quality is so similar but the opal takes
just seconds to set up and take down and
it is Tiny so you could take it with you
pretty much everywhere you go I also
tested a tough scenario that a lot of us
find ourselves in and that is being
backlit by a light source like a window
which can really lower the contrast and
make the image look too dark since the
sensor lens and processing really
struggles in this situation here you can
see that the MacBook camera looks worse
than before while the opal still has a
super detailed image without artifacts
and you can easily see my face now Apple
recently started allowing you to connect
your iPhone to your laptop so I decided
to compare it to the very best iPhone
own my 14 pro Max which has the amazing
48 megapixel sensor and while it looks
better than the built-in webcam it can't
even compete with the Oppo while having
a lot less detail and some massive lens
flare due to the lens design now of
course with that your iPhone is also
locked up so you cannot use it if you
end up needing to while you're using it
as a webcam and if you touch it the
webcam shuts off and lastly in worst lit
environments which many find themselves
the macbook's webcam starts to look
really bad and that's the best MacBook
webcam and the difference with the opal
is just insane that is because the Opel
has a really nice Sony sensor that is
the largest ever put into a webcam and
an F 1.86 element lens with that it has
a very powerful Intel Myriad X chip for
processing so the hardware is very
impressive and I didn't even mention the
mic mesh yet which is an rate of mics
both on the front Behind these holes and
on the back that make your audio sound
great now the other side of it is its
software which is easy to use but is
also very powerful you can just set it
to Auto and it looks great or you could
dive into the manual settings to fine
tune your image and I appreciate that
you don't have to go full manual but you
could just tune the settings that you
want there's a bunch of settings
including touch up and tone sync to
match your room along with tunable bokeh
which looks way better than the
over-the-top locked in bokeh of the
MacBooks webcam you can add logos and
overlays Zoom have face tracking and
even record and loop your webcam along
with tuning for your audio it's not
often that you get a product that is
quick and easy to use but also very high
quality both in the build and the
quality of the image and since it is so
small I have been keeping it with me in
my bag at all times there's a reason why
so many creatives and professionals
bought it when it was a limited release
invite only product but it is now
available to buy so if you're tired of
your webcam footage looking terrible or
you just want to step up to something
that looks phenomenal go ahead and check
out the opal using the link down below
thank you guys for watching the spin Max
click that Circle above to subscribe and
I will see you in the next video